storyline number 11 for the 2019 season
and it could go a lot higher by the time
week one rolls around what will the
impact be
of the new rule that allows for replay
review of pass interference both
offensive and defensive both called and
not called this is all a reaction to
what we saw in the nfc championship game
when there was a blatant instance of
past interference that wasn't called the
nfl i think has overreacted by making
all instances of interference called and
not called subject to replay review it's
potentially going to be a mess for
reasons we have discussed at length at
profootballtalk.com and on pft live and
also on the pftpm podcast for now the
point is this
whether or not it's going to affect the
nfl's 100 season hovers over the weeks
leading up to the start of the campaign
and just like last year with that helmet
rule that we saw affect the preseason
the first couple of weeks in a very
negative way the nfl on the fly fixed it
the challenge this year once we see how
this
replay review and especially automatic
review in the final two minutes of
either half of pass interference is
going to play out will the nfl mobilize
to fix it and ultimately will the
commissioner be the one who quite
possibly has to pull aside senior vp of
officiating our river honor and say look
look
this is a very high bar that we're going
to apply to overturning these rulings
this is just a mechanism for preventing
another outcome like the one that we saw
in the ram saints game this isn't about
opening the door to all sorts of of
reversals of past interference that
wasn't called or was called and we're
gonna look at it frame by frame and slow
it down and second guess the rulings on
the field i think if necessary the
commissioner needs to say that to al
river on and now river on needs to
follow it because the last thing we need
a bunch of stoppages late in games a
bunch of reversals based upon
questionable evidence it needs to truly
be clear and obvious and the one thing
that's clear and obvious for now it's a
story that will hover over the nfl's
100th season until we see that new rule
be applied in a way that makes us all
say okay we get it this is just there as
protection against the kind of worst
case scenario that we saw in the nfc
championship game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports